il est temps d'aller chasser le pokémon
les amis pokémon go est sorti même pas
enfin sorti est ralliée aux us et c'est
pourtant déjà un gros buzz en france on
a pu se procurer l'application
aujourd'hui on va chasser pokémon dans
les rues de paris je plus ardus à la
mèche du bulbizarre du quart à puce oak
sommes nous plus haut mais on est tous
un peu plus haut du coup cette année
parce qu'on va toucher à ces pokémon ne
va pas se mentir allez suivez moi à
suivez le guide
on y va donc là juste à droite c'est
carré bleu sont en fait des pokerstop et
si je vais à proximité je peux faire
tourner la pièce et je gagnerai par
exemple les poké ball ou une castration
n'y a que de la merde une belle question
bat les couilles il ya un deuxième
pokerstop qui est collée au progrès stop
ça c'est bien
j'essaie de dire ça car à puce et pas
loin de là je tourne la pièce et vu que
c'est pas sorti en france et qu'un une
connexion de merde
et bah ça tourne dans le vide
apparemment il ya remis house qui est
pas très loin à et un petit arts et des
rats tata mais sans s'emballer course et
des petits rats de façon régulièrement
et vous la mort aux rats et créeront qu
on les capture s'est rarement des cons
il pleut qu'est ce que ça vous êtes plus
tu te dis que je te dise que ça 107 plus
ça sent carapuce non non non non thor
tank sa senteur tank là aujourd'hui
c'est un peu la crise est passé le 14
juillet les pokémon hier ils ont fait la
fête donc ils sont encore dans leur lit
donc je pourrais faire là c'est que je
vais utiliser une baie vous voyez une
baie n'importe quoi je vais utiliser un
encens et un instant c'est simple ça va
me permettre finalement d'avoir des
pokémon plus souvent voilà par exemple
carapuce haut on a vraiment envie qui
termine dans notre inventaire donc on va
tout faire au
il ya un aspect qu il ya un aspect qu il
y en a sur il est là il est là il est là
je suis écarte tout attention attention
madame st jean écartez vous
c'est bon attention est ce qu'on l'a
capturé à l'éco high five ça c'est ça ça
montre bien la rivalité entre chasseurs
c'est à dire que c'est un petit peu
chacun sa gueule quoi tout le monde veut
c'est pokémon fin à la tension avant spa
il ya juste là bas un rat tata lui il a
évité la mort aux rats le conflit va
finir un autre pokéball veut dire qu'il
aurait préféré la mort aux rats ça bug
excusez moi j'aurais vu un rat tata pas
loin c'est un petit rat qu'on met dans
notre pokéball non cette adresse aux aa
par bon c'est une poker infirmières
[ __ ] par contre et quand ça pouvoir se
faire un nom
alors attention et un noceur était juste
là oh le con il dérange les mecs du
chantier que j'ai raté à pokéball ouais
j'ai mon os ferati génos karachi merci
beaucoup
y'a un yaoi il ya un pas qu'on va
pouvoir aller chasser et ce qui est bien
c'est que j'ai une chasse son évolution
dont je m'en bats les couilles bien vous
allez donc là ce qui va se passer c'est
qu'on va marcher quatre kilomètres et
demi et qu'au bout d'un moment j'ai des
yeux qui vont être l'or est ensuite on
pourra avoir un 9 10 km se veut dire que
dedans il y aura un pokémon de type de
type légendaire voilà un gros pokémon tu
vois un pompier du rata bouge pas bouge
ça bouge ça bouge ça bouge pas il ya un
show ni quand il ya un show nippon il
est juste là oui oui allait rendre la
pac et borna le poké ball
voilà j'ai l'habitude j'en prends tous
les jours des chenilles prof chez soi
faire ce que tu veux s'explique je
t'expliquerai pas on va aller là-bas il
ya une arène donc un pokémon go en fait
il ya trois équipes étant rejoint une
level 5
il ya les rouges les jaunes et les
attentions classe est là c'est un piège
moyen terme avec julien pierre chadebech
attends bouge pas bush palais sur ton
sac ne bouge surtout pas ne bouge pas
c'est dangereux fabec mon gars tu
acceptes fief avec ses pokémon que
personne n'était sur ton sac tient lui
voulait tour un level 5 dans pokémon go
tu rejoins l'une des trois équipes la
bleue la jaune ou la rouge
moi j'ai rejoint la bleue la bayanne à
rennes qui a été prise par les rouges
moi ce que je vous propose c'est qu'on a
violé ces [ __ ] de pokémon rouge et
quand je dis violet la couleur je parle
pas de la couleur que tu veux que tu
fais là où flex et ça attention
attention attention attention c'est quoi
c'est un piaf c'est un rond cool mais
qu'est ce qu'on s'en bat les coûts d'un
oublié là il est devant nous ok ok ah
voilà allez c'est bon donc là la reine
tu vois ce jardin ça c'est la reine ça
donc elle est rouge il ya trois pokémon
qui la protègent et un petit rat
t'attaques le mail 266,1 roux carnage
2448 est un magma 682 donc les mains qui
se croient chaud il dit ça y est on est
les rouges rouge c'est la couleur du feu
on efforts on va leur montrer ce que
valent les bleus et je parle pas de
l'équipe de france aussi on a vu ce
qu'ils valent et la coupe du monde
c'était grandiose
ok on y est je vais lancer le combat je
vais mettre perçu en je vais mettre un
sécateur je vais mettre mon flag à dos
c'est parti on a en pleine baston
on va sur leur attaque hop hop hop hop
hop
allez rattataki les morts suivant hop
hop hop et là on va lancer la méga
attaque sedrak aux chocs
je vais pas te mentir le carnage il n'a
fait aucun carnage et la magma on va pas
lui faire la grosse compétences de
réflexes qui inflige énormément de
dégâts voilà ça lui a retiré que dallas
y voit là sa vie vient de chuter et puis
tilman et la reine a chuté avec la la
reine elle est vierge
j'appuie dessus et hop on flex vas-y ça
me rapportera des points tous les jours
je gagne des poussières les pièces pour
chaque pokémon que tu as dans des arènes
tous les jours ou plus tard elle plutôt
qu'une telle venir de pokémon putté
meilleurs dresseurs
là on va aller se faire une autre arène
autant cecos à lisser les mêmes les
mêmes mecs avaient une arène là bas on
soit faire c'est qu'on va aller cela
prend donc la reine c'est quoi c'est
l'école sainte-marie classe aa du groupe
la capture c'est ça que bien du coup on
est baisé
ok on est arrivé devant la reine elle
ressemble à ça allume ses fenêtres a
probablement li pou tout qui nous
regardent et qui se chie dessus on
arrive cet arrêt n'est trop loin bon
alors quand c'est comme ça vous sonnez
et vouloir expliquer la situation oui
bonjour madame je viens pour combattre
le lit poutou qui gardent les lieux s'il
vous plaît d'accord comment on peut
faire du pouf aujourd'hui et demain
d'accord j'aimerais quand même que vous
dit que vous dites à votre écoute ou
d'arrêter de me faire des doigts depuis
la fenêtre parce que c'est pas très
sympa parce que quand même à ce point de
montleau classe dans son cul il fera
moins le malin tony poutou merde
j'aurais d'abord là là à temps il ya mon
petit poulain il ya mon petit poulain
qui va naître après 5 kilomètres
attention j'aimerais trop un truc fou
genre 1-1 salamèche un quart a pu mais
c'est un truc incroyable
annie d'oran c'est beau c'est pourquoi
je souris puisque je suis un petit peu
pareil qu'au départ on lui sorti de
l'oeuf comme ça et c'était déçu puis
c'est ce que je fais quand je vais pas
bien je me branle mais pas que je prends
aussi les arènes et là il ya la team
or qu'est pas loin donc la ja jeu car à
bruz type nomades et héroux carnage et
prendre un sécateur je vais prendre père
cyan avec flag à dos on va défoncer les
jaunes mon pote c'est parti là il ya un
petit scarabée
alors là giroud carnage là ça va être la
fête je vais envoyer que des sorts qui
font très très mal au hockey bon au
carnage en effet deux à lui tout seul
puis le petit dernier on va se faire
avec skarabot tu d'accord mon chien
avril pu la merde on va prendre de la
paire cyan et ouais les gars je vous ai
défoncé on a pris la reine elle est à
nous au monde un petit arrêt plus qu'à
deux pas si tu arrivé qu'à deux pas il
doit être pareil doit être par là je les
jeux les jeux les il était là il était
là elle était en train de faire c'est un
point scrupuleux cours sur les marches
alors est ce qu'on a bon bah du coup un
pouvoir
on va se poser à la maison on va boire
le thé puis on va on va faire
connaissance avec les pokémon qu'on a
capturé station n'a pu battre il va
devoir rentrer c'est juste la droite ah
bah tiens ça c'est juste ici à
l'intérieur mais à part non pas juste
par là on voulait pas du tout filmé ici
bonjour bonjour en fait il me feel me
filme en train de jouer à pokémon gold
c'est un jeu qui se fait dans la rue en
fait les pokémon dans les rues barrées
c'est pas une blague fondation promis je
rêvais